[Music]
las vegas will welcome thousands of
sports fans in one of our busiest
weekends in a few years major sporting
events taking place from friday right to
sunday this saturday you have the las
vegas lights you have the aviators
playing over at the las vegas ballpark
you have a ufc fight at t-mobile taking
place and then sunday the headline and
events nascar with the south point 400
at the las vegas motor speedway the
night's pre-season opener starts at
t-mobile we're not done the raiders
facing miami at allegiant stadium of
course these weekend events expected to
really boost the local economy chris
matthews will have much more coming up
in your sports report
with such a busy sports weekend that
means so many options and that is
driving down some ticket prices eight
news now reporter sally jeremiah spoke
to a ticket agency on when to strike on
the good deals it's a careful process
she joins us live from the strip we're
heading into quite a weekend sally
that's right brian well these ticket
brokers tell me with these cheaper
tickets it's a great time to hang out
with the family this weekend without
breaking the bank
we love sports we have a very
competitive nature in our family it's a
great way to spend time quality time
with family and it's a great way to
build memories sonia pedowick has lived
in las vegas for 20 years she has three
kids ages 11 14 15. she says going to
sporting events as a family of five it
can be very expensive so they can always
go together you know some people try to
wait as long as they can and we call
like catch the knife at the bottom and
you know sometimes you miss and you can
mis miss the knife entirely or sometimes
you get cut toby baptist is the vice
president of operations at las
vegastickets.com he says so many events
at once is driving down prices the
golden knights preseason game is cheaper
than a regular season game would be with
lois tickets going for 30 or 40 dollars
he says having quarterbacks for both
teams injured is driving down raider
dolphin tickets vivid seats had those
starting at about 160 dollars pricing
for the events is all going to vary
based on
you know certain factors going into as
far as you know who the team that
they're playing what's going on with the
players and and what the game means so
when is the best time to buy when you
see the seat that you want to sit in for
a price that you're you're comfortable
with paying you know that would be the
time to buy the ticket
and we have prices for all the events on
eight news now dot com another tip make
sure it's coming from a trusted source
reporting live sally jaramillo live
local now